hey y'all attended catch here in this
tuesday video we're going to be going
over
an important concept when dealing with
neural networks
and that is transfer learning so
transfer
learning is basically using a already
made neural network
and basically tweaking it so it can fit
to your data
a common usage in uh transfer warning is
using like bert models
to compute um embeddings from uh text
and then using that to feed into
another model um what's really cool
about
transfer learning is we're basically
using these large companies resources
and for our own side projects so i guess
with like google
um their most popular thing is like bert
which is a text model
and when i was reading about it i think
bert took like a month to train on
um using google services or servers so
you can see how
there's a lot of comp computational
resources that goes into these models
and we as data scientists and hobbyists
can basically just use these models
without going through all the work of
basically ruining
our laptops and stuff like that so and
that's what we're going to do today
we're going to do some transfer learning
i'm actually not going to be using burke
because bird actually takes a lot of
preprocessing to get into it
i'm instead i'm basically going to use a
token based um embeddings model
but um you can bur is definitely very
useful to use
but it also highlights one of the
problems with tf hub where there's not a
lot of documentation
and there's not a lot of examples for
our users it's definitely more
catered towards a python stack um so you
definitely would have to go through all
the uh
[Music]
you know the the examples of it try to
see what's going on with it
but um if you get it um if you get used
to it
and um start learning how the
pre-processing works
and you'll definitely get uh rewarded in
the end so let's actually load up a
our markdown file um and we're gonna
call this tidy tuesday uh
transfer morning yep and then
what we're actually gonna do is load in
a few packages
the tidy verse uh
tidy models uh tidy
text themis
uh tf hub and keras
oops cares we're also going to read in
our csv which is harry
pottertext.csv
so when looking at this csv um there's
four columns
a movie a character and a house we
really care mostly about
i guess the character house and text um
so let's actually look at um
the total characters so characters
oh it's character right character we
have a decent amount of characters we
have about 247
characters um but i'm kind of curious
because if we actually look at
our data we can see a character show up
multiple times
because the text that i the data set
that i created was basically
um showing whenever a character would
speak and just record that instance so
i'm curious basically when a character
actually talks
how many words do they do they say
so let's do that so let's select the uh
dialog let's create a pk to represent
the uh instance someone said something
and then let's unnested tokens so our
output
will be words our input will be uh
dialog and our token will be
words and then let's actually count the
pk because i'll just count
on the instances of words and just do a
summary
so we can see here that um
we have a decent amount of words being
said um
it's kind of interesting uh to see what
we're doing but
uh let's see what is actually going on
um
for the total amount of words someone
says
so it says i should do it by character
so let's do select
uh character dialogue
let's just do house too
okay and then let's actually create
basically an index so let's do a
nest tokens output
will be words input
is equal to dialog and our token
is words uh token output
unuse unness tokens
token what is finesse token
output input diode token equals work
what's going on here
uh-oh you have to go in the tidy text a
little bit
okay i wonder what's going on
click dialog and we'd say
a nest tokens output
equals word we'll say word input equals
dialog
and then token equals words
okay whatever so what i actually want to
do is basically
um create more samples so if i actually
do a like
count character
um and then just do a summary we would
see that characters actually talk a
decent amount right
so like on average a character will say
like 50 things
um so i'm basically gonna convert these
sequences
um into batches of 50. so if someone
says 50 words
uh we're basically gonna um says more
than 50 words so i got 100 words we're
going to split that into two little
pieces
uh so let's do that
um so first i want to actually do that
and then create a
um dialog ispk which will be
let's do a row number
okay and then we'll say uh uh we'll just
do a group
by uh character house
uh dialogue pk
and then i just make a word index so
let's say word index equals row
number okay
and then we'll actually create this word
index
then we'll actually create like a
sequence index so we can basically see
see that okay we have like like maybe
over 50 words we want to split
this area into another sequence so we'll
just do a sequence
index is equal to word round word
index divided by
50.
yep and then what we'll do is group by
character
house uh dialog pk
and then sequence index and summarize it
and say
text is equal to concatenate word
sep equals space and then collapse
equals
space what do we see here
uh i think we did it we have about that
much
um and then we can do it ungroup
okay and then we can select the
character oops character
house
x make a new pk just to check so pk
equals row
number one nest tokens
a nest tokens output equals
word input equals text
uh tokens equals uh words
uh unless token i'll put
output equals word input equals x
right token oh token
equals words
and then we can count the pk
we do the summary and we see our pk
uh shows that uh our max amount of words
for uh sequence is 51
which makes sense so what we can do now
is basically just deselect the character
and just select the house and the text
okay and if we look at it
our house if you look at the house which
what
is what we're trying to predict we can
see we have a decent
amount of of classes a lot of
gryffindors but we want to remove the no
entries so so uh df filter
house is not equal to no
entry
count the house again now we removed it
oops uh okay
so with the uh our created data set for
our actual model um if we actually look
at our house again or i guess we can
yeah we just do it right here um we can
see that it's imbalanced
and one of the things i'm gonna do is
i'm basically just gonna
rebalance it using up sampling so we
have a decent amount of samples for
our model um i definitely think that
there's gonna be information leakage
because
realistically like it's gonna see some
repeated uh
some repeated houses but i think that's
fine for this
um uh example
um so let's let's actually just do it so
let's do a house
data equal df and we'll say step
uh sample house
uh prep it and then juice it
okay we have our uh
our uh or say balance out
classes we have our balanced classes
um if we count our house
we counter houses we now have equal
amounts of uh
the actual classes so let's actually
start doing the modeling
specifically with the neural networks so
one thing that we have to do is we have
to convert this house
uh into uh basically numeric data so
we'll say
mutate house is equal to as dot
numeric house
um and then it converts it to ones and
four so we do like a summary
it's one through four but we actually
can't do that we actually have to do
uh minus one so we'll just do that
because uh with
uh tensorflow and keras it's zero base
so that'll be zero one two and three
i'm actually gonna make an index or a
dictionary so let's say house
i'll say house
label is equal to house house as dot
numeric
um right there so we'll say select house
label and house
distinct this will be kind of our
dictionary for our
uh um for us to reference and then what
we're actually gonna do is
uh create our
create our actual um classes for our
neural network so
did that right and then we can just say
df
right there um i will say since
uh we did some preprocessing it converts
this text into a factor
uh we actually don't want that so we'll
say x is equal to as that
character text cool
so now we have our processed data um
let's create our splits so we'll say uh
set
dot seed is 23 and then we'll say
tidy split is training of tidy
initial split our df
and our train data will be our
training
and our test data will be our testing
data set
cool and then what we actually have to
do is
uh process our data for our neural
network luckily we don't actually have
to do anything for our text
uh because our transfer model that we're
gonna be using uh it doesn't really
require anything it'll do the
pre-pressing
pre-processing by itself but we still
have to pre-process the categorical
variables so
i'm just gonna create a train uh text
which would be our train data
um text and then i'll say our train
tables which would be two categorical
two categorical train
data and then house
we'll create our test uh text
would be our test data text
and then our test labels which will be
our test
data house
to categorical test house
okay do the same thing right here
and if we look at our train text uh i
think
length see we have 18 uh thousand
and then we do our thing right here the
same thing but we have four classes we
also look at our test
text m uh oh it's notes it's a length
all right six thousand and their test
labels which will be
the same thing with four okay so we're
actually using
um a google tensorflow
model i actually have it in a different
window let me
copy and paste it up here
which is the g news swivel a token based
embedding trained off of the google news
130 gigabyte corpus so obviously i would
never
just you know download a 100 gigabytes
of text data and
run an auto encoder or whatever they did
for it but luckily they did
and they did all the work for us so i'll
show you how easy it is to use
like a token-based embedding model um
using keras
so the first thing you have to do is
actually create the layer i'm just going
to call it embeddings
and we actually call in the layer hub
because we're just
kind of grabbing it from the tensorflow
hub we give it the actual
link uh using the handle
and we'll also set that the trainable is
equal to false because we're not trying
to adjust the weights
or the embeddings we're actually just
going to use the embeddings itself
okay and now what we have to do is
actually kind of um
showing how really how neural networks
work in general
but we have to create the inputs and the
outputs so our input
or our model will be layer input
um our shape for it will actually be um
different sizes because the layer the
embeddings will basically do the work
for us
but we also have to set the data type
which is a string
and now we actually have to just do our
output so our output will be our
input layer our embeddings layer
and then let's just do some dense layers
so units is equal to
i don't know like 64 just because we
have a lot
not a lot of data um and we already have
some embedding so
we don't have to go too crazy into deep
learning just do a railway
layer dense units equals 32 activation
equals relu because we're just doing a
second layer
and then we'll just do our activation
layer which we have for classes
and since it's a multi-class
multi-classification
we'll use a softmax activation function
so let's actually go over this so we
have our input which basically saying
like we don't really know the shape of
it um
we'll worry about it later but we know
it's a string because that's our text
and then we basically just downloaded
the model the embeddings model and this
will basically do the pre-processing
pre-processing for us and then output um
some embeddings um nodes and after we
get those embeddings it's just going to
feed right into
our standard neural network model so as
you can see it's very easy like it's
literally just one line of code to make
an
embedding model using like 150 gigabytes
of text data
from google so it's pretty
straightforward but there's a lot of
pre-processing pre-processing that goes
into
using like other models like bert um
some uh some computer vision models so
um is deceptively easy um we're not
trying to do anything crazy
i just wanted to say that uh
okay so now let's actually create our
model since we have our inputs and our
outputs so
keras model and we just give it our
input
and our output right
and then let's actually compile it using
i guess
our loss will be a categorical
cross entropy i really hope i don't
spell it wrong
optimizer will be atom you can obviously
change it to like
uh anything else like sgd and stuff like
that
and then our metrics will be accuracy
instead of roc aoc
because we have it balanced um
artificially
okay now let's actually just do our
traditional fits
um our x will be our train
uh was it our train text right or why
is our train labels
let's say a validation splits of 80 20.
and i was actually typing in validation
split wrong um you're actually supposed
to do 0.2
over 0.8 um that's definitely my fault i
i could have swore i read it on
deep learning but that was 0.8 but it's
0.2
uh just to make sure that you guys are
doing it correctly and then we'll just
call 50 uh ebooks
so we're going to be training it uh we
can see our we're going in
oh did it not do the oh i spelt
validation split wrong
that's fine i guess we'll just keep on
going through it using our own
model and we see our actually is slowly
increasing
our loss is slowly decreasing
and it should keep going going
i probably won't rerun this using the
validation set um i think this video
might get a little long
and to be honest this is a pretty simple
concept so let's just do a post
evaluation on our on our test set and
see how it reacts
okay i'm just gonna wait for that to go
in i'm gonna
make sure my obs still running and i'll
just type in the evaluate
give it our model give it our test text
and our test
labels
okay and we can see we have similar
accuracy right 75
actually 75 test evaluation actually
that it hasn't seen
obviously a technique probably has seen
it um so there is a lot of data leakage
here
but that's definitely not what we should
be doing
because we pre-processed it beforehand
but when i
actually created this harry potter
soaring hat model the main idea was that
people would use it for fun um this
isn't really for like there's no actual
like validation for saying that like
you're not a gryffindor or not it's
mostly just
using your text and semantically seeing
how you how you speak
like uh which house you speak like um so
ideally what we really want is more
of a diverse amount of predictions over
pure
accurate predictions uh because the data
we gave it
technically it's just mostly it's gonna
be gryffindor because it's highly
imbalanced
right so if we go back to our was our
counts of our classes
did i do that yeah i kind of it would
pretty much
always try to predict gryffindor because
that'll be maximizing
um it's it's uh it's objective function
to to get the highest accuracy but in
reality if it's always predicting
gryffindor
people won't trust the model uh even
though
technically they shouldn't trust the
model because it's it's not scientific
at all
um but you want something that has a
pretty good use case and in this case
i wanted to predict a wide variety of it
so people can have fun you know they can
analyze their own tweets and texts and
then say like oh well i'm a gryffindor
and you're a slytherin
that's funny um and stuff like that um
that's just me going on tangent on
actual like
applications and also the data science
part of it but let's actually look at
our
uh confusion matrix for our evaluation
set so
we're actually going to predict using
our model given our test text
and we'll convert that to a table what's
fun is it gives the model
uh the probabilities are ready so we'll
say um
model thread um
and then with our model pred let's just
add our classes
which will be the test labels
uh right testing oh no it's not that uh
test data and then we'll say
house and we'll say uh we'll convert
that to it as
table house is equal to that
right so we have our uh oops
um so we have our house
um what's actually left join our
dictionary so
uh house oops house
dick right is it is that that um what
would i call it again
sorry about that label dick label dick
so
label dick and we'll just kept that
right so now we have our labels
um we'll select our minus house
right and then what we can do is
um oh actually let me sorry about that
uh model pred
who's model pred you can actually change
the column column names pretty fast
using the uh
label dict um we'll just select
house label plug
the list
um right
and then i believe we can just say like
call names
to get to that's right and then we can
look at our model pred
oops uh plug select
and maybe
looked house label uh was it
pluck one
and then let's okay again there we go
so now we re we made that um we can add
this stuff into it
um oh sorry
and then we can create our confusion
matrix so uh conf
uh what what do we do uh
conf matt and then truth is equal to
house label estimate is equal to griff
indoor to slytherin
on bar must oh
oh that's why
uh was it uh and then we can do a what
is it
um mutate pk
is equal to row number
sorry about that i'm a little
scatterbrained and then we just do a
pivot longer minus pk
and house label and then
group by house label
and pk and then summarize value is equal
to
uh max value
um and then
we can do that and then we jesus uh
filter and value is equal to max
value and then we can select minus value
pivot and then we have that
right um we can mutate name is as that
factor
as name and then we can do a confusion
matrix which is truth is equal to
house label estimate is equal to
name
and then we have to uh on group
there we go and we see our model did
very well
um one thing it's doing it's really
missing the uh the gryffindors
so that's kind of interesting but it's
getting the slithers pretty well
um so let's actually look at our roc auc
okay so we can just do our right there
and then let's compute our roc auc
our truth is equal to our uh house
label our estimate is equal to
uh griffin griff
and door to slytherin
uh slid they're in
estimate
what what uh grif so it's gryffindor to
[Music]
slytherin normal estimate must match
oh maybe i have to just remove estimate
there we go
and we can see our roc aoc score is
pretty high
on 91 percent which is definitely better
of 91 which is definitely beating
um a random guess and
we can see that we kind of cheated
because we did some up uh some up
sampling so it's definitely seeing a lot
of it but realistically
the data set we actually have um is
imbalanced
and in the world of harry potter it
should be pretty balanced so
i'm fine with doing that um some things
that we could have predict
or change is we could just change it to
down sampling uh that would have been
interesting to do um
we'd also change the um the the transfer
warning model so we could have done
maybe a sequence a sequential model but
the main idea behind this entire video
was that
transfer learning is pretty easy to do a
lot of simple things
um and it's definitely something that
you should keep in your
tool kit because um you can definitely
get some decent amount
of predictive power for it with doing
none of the work
and allowing these larger companies to
do it for you
so i'll see you guys next week and tidy
on